هي ضربه موجعه بلا شك بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي في ريخوفت في العمق الاسرائيلي
قريبا من تل ابيب هذا هو القتيل الاول في
هذه المعركه من الجانب الاسرائيلي ونذكر
ربما طيله الوقت كانت هناك محاولات من قبل
الجانب الاسرائيلي منذ بدء هذه الجوله
بمحاوله حصر هذه المعركه في جبهه غزه في
البلدات الحدوديه في منطقه غلاف غزه
وعولت كثيرا ربما الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه بان ان يكون مدى الصواريخ
اقصاه هذه المناطق والا تصل هذه الصواريخ
اول القذائف الصاروخيه الى منطقه الجان
الى منطقه تل ابيب وجنوب تل ابيب وحتى ما
يعرف بتل ابيب الكبرى وهي هذه المنطقه
المحيطه بمنطقه تل ابيب لكن منذ يوم امس
ومنذ بدا اطلاق الصواريخ مباشره لم يتم
استثناء هذه المنطقه على الاطلاق وكانت
ضمن نطاق المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
وطالتها صافرات الانذار والصواريخ ورصدنا
يوم امس ونحن هنا عده مرات تم فيها اعتراض
للصواريخ في هذه المناطق لكن هذا اليوم
اخفقت منظومه القبه الحديديه في اعتراض
هذه الدفعات من الصواريخ ما تسبب بسقوط
صاروخ مباشره على هذا
المبنى ومن الواضح بان تداعي بنيامين
نتنياهو الى جلسه مشاورات امنيه عاجله مع
وزير الدفاع
وبالمناسبه مباشره بعد هذه الضربه جمال
بدا يعقد مشاورات على مستويات اخرى مع
السكرتير العسكري للحكومه واخرين بعد قليل
ستبدا هنا بعد قرابه نصف ساعه ستبدا في تل
ابيب في مقر وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
جلسه مشاورات اخرى يعقدها رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو مع وزير الدفاع
بطبيعه الحال من المتوقع ان يتم بحث هذه
الضربه
تداعيات هذه الضربه تاثير وانعكاسات هذه
الضربه على
الاسرائيليين على الشارع
وعلى المستوى الامني والسياسي
يقول على جميع مواطني اسرائيل
الاستماع بعنايه الى تعليمات قياده الجبهه
الداخليه ماذا يعني هنا
نعم هذا يكرره بطبيعه الحال
بنيامين نتنياهو منذ بدايه هذه
الجوله وهذا اليوم كان قد تواجد في مقر
عسكري لمنظومه الدفاع الجويه لاعتراض
الصواريخ بعيده المدى مقلاع داود والتي تم
تجريبها يوم امس في اعتراض قذيفه وصلت الى
منطقه تل ابيب قال من هناك ايضا وطالبه
مواطني اسرائيل بالانصياع والاستماع
والالتزام بالتعليمات التي تفرضها الجبهه
الداخليه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي طلب
منهم ان يساعدوا ما وصفه
الجانب السياسي والجانب العسكري من اجل
حمايتهم في هذا في هذه التصريحات سبقت
وصول هذه القذائف الى منطقه ريحوفت
ظهر نتنياهو بنوع من التباهي والتفاخر بان
الاسرائيلي تمكن بجهود مشتركه مع قوات
المخابرات الاسرائيليه الداخليه الشباك من
تنفيذ عمليات اغتيال اخرى لقاده في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وقال فليعرف الجميع ان كل
من يقوم
بالحاق الضرر باسرائيل او مواطنيها سيتم
سيكون دمه مهدورا وحتى من سينوب عنه كذلك
وتحدث عن استهداف القائد في الجهاد
الاسلامي قبل فجر هذا اليوم غاليه وقال
بانه تم ايضا
اغتيال نائبه بعد ذلك لكن انا يعني من
المتوقع ان حاليا نتنياهو ما كان ليتحدث
بهذا التباهي بدات تسمع في اسرائيل
انتقادات واسعه بعد هذه الضربه الموجعه في
ريخوفوت جمال انتقادات لعدم تقدير هذه
الحكومه وتقدير نتنياهو عن التوقيت
المناسب من وجهه نظرهم لانهاء هذه المعركه
ويعني يكاد يجمع الاسرائيليون حاليا على
ان الاوضاع بدات تتعقد اكثر وقد ربما في
حال لم تتخذ قرارات على المستوى السياسي
من قبل القياده السياسيين في اسرائيل
بايجاد مخرج
من هذه المعركه ستتدهور الامور الى حرب
شامله وهذا ما لا تريده اسرائيل وايضا ما
لا يريده الاسرائيليون